mais tu crois qu'on peut rire de tout ça
dépend qui écoutent rire de tout si tu
fais du mal à la personne qui écoute val
va te dire qu'on n'a pas le droit de
rire de tout on ne peut pas sortir une
blague antisémites à des gens qui
viennent faire un un pèlerinage à
auschwitz c'est pas le moment
maintenant ces gens là ils ont l'humour
juif et si tu veux leur dire des choses
et ben attend qu'ils soient disponibles
mais quand tu dis par exemple que ton
grand père a fait du cinéma qui est joué
dans le menu en berne granby là qu'il a
finie mannequin chez mon savon est ce
que tu crois qu'on peut rire de ça dit
ça pour pas qu'on oublie un jour j'ai
été voir un pote son père il s'est
occupé du film shoah
celui qui a produit et je vais dit alors
ça te fait rire dit oui parce qu'on en
parle parce que les gens n'oublieront
pas ce que tu es religieux j'ai des
coutumes j'aime quand j'arrive chez moi
un soir de fête
voir mon père et ma mère heureux ma mère
elle a préparé le dîner
elle est heureuse mon père et les chefs
de famille et en bout de table
il a le sourire on est ensemble on perd
mais sa main sur ma tête
et puis je me sens protégée j'oublie mes
soucis parce que tu crois en dieu dieu
existe
il existe quelques aujourd'hui on peut
pas dire autre chose que ce soit lui qui
ait créé les hommes les hommes qui est
créé dieu de toute façon il existe mais
c'est pas grave
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de il
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux